tu es venu faire le
malin devant nos fans et mon frère qui
est là tu as mis une bonne vieille
raclée à la mode
Texas tu es le passé mon vieux et nous
lair de ce sport alors tuarrêes pas de
courir
[Applaudissements]
the
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
what you say about Compan
what
tu as mis du temps à te remettre debout
ouais j'étais jamais tombé au sol aussi
violemment tu dois encaisser et te
relevé ouais je sais il était pas censé
me jeter hors du ring il m'a pris par
surprise je pouvais rien faire et
physiquement j'arrivais plus à bouger
c'est leur façon de te tester
moi je veux être avec ma famille je vais
être avec mes frères c'est trop mignon
et qu'est-ce que vous faites quand vous
êtes
ensemble to et
rien je sais pas
trop quand on est ensemble on est
capable de
tout et toi alors moi je veux devenir
vétérinaire je veux des enfants je veux
mon propre cabinet je veux un homme qui
est d'accord avec
ça cool toi tu serais d'accord avec ça
un peu que je seraai d'accord on serait
comme un de ces super coupes modernes on
aurait notre R chanous et tout le monde
pourrait venir vivre avec nous mes
frères leur famille
d'accord
to rise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ear are allill
with than
[Musique]
God would
myamond have my fiddle and my F tool
thank God i'm a Country
Boy driving in a black a lot of S people
that's ke let me tell you now exactly
what I mean I thank God i'm a Country
Boy